hey this is press tow
Walker here's a really interesting
question if x to the power of x to the
power of 8 is equal to 8 solve for x or
X is a positive real number I saw this
on Reddit
askmath pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this
problem
[Music]
I first want to review an important
point if you have a to the power of B to
the power of C this means to evaluate B
to the power of C
first in other words you could put a
parentheses around B to the power of C
this will not be the same thing if you
have a to the power of b as a group term
raised to the power of C so for example
let's say you have 2 to the^ of 3^ 2 you
need to evaluate 3^2 first so this is
equal to 2 ^ of 9 which is then equal to
500 and
12 now if instead you had 2 to the^ of
three grouped first and you square that
then you would be taking 2 ^ 3 first 2 ^
3 is equal to 8 then 8^2 will be equal
to 64 so you can see that these two
things are not the same thing you want
to evaluate the exponents going from the
top so how do we solve our problem we
have x to the power of x to ^ 8 is equal
to
8 now one thing we could do is we could
graph it we can see here we just have
positive real values of X this is going
to grow EXP exponentially the line Y is
equal to 8 is a straight line and the
two graphs intersect exactly once so if
we go down to the x value we can
estimate that it's approximately equal
to
1.3 now how do we get a better value for
this how do we solve this
equation so I just want to briefly
illustrate how you can solve this
problem numerically in a spreadsheet
this isn't the best way to go about it
but there are times s in life your boss
May order you to put something in a
spreadsheet so you could show to the
client so let's just say you're stuck on
a desert island and you only have access
to a spreadsheet how can you numerically
estimate the answer so let's say you set
cell A1 to be the value X and then B1
we're going to say is the value of x to
the power of the term x to the power of
8 you want to make sure you group these
exponents because Excel would otherwise
go from left to right right which is not
correct so we know that the answer is
approximately
1.3 and we're going to take this value
to the power of the same value to the
power of 8 so we end up with 8.5 now we
want this to be eight by changing the
value of x so in order to do that you go
to the data
tab what if analysis and goal seek so we
want to set the value of B2 to be equal
to 8 and we want to do this by changing
the value of
A2 so we click okay and it's going to do
some computation and it ends up giving
us an approximate solution of
1.29 68 and this is actually very very
close to the actual
answer so this is just an interesting
way that you could solve it in
spreadsheets so now that we know that
this does have a real solution we're not
going to be too worried about things
like convergence we're just going to
have a little bit of
fun so let's take a look at this problem
we have eight as an exponent here but we
also look at the entire equation that 8
is equal to X to ^ x to the^ of 8 so
what if we took this 8 and we
substituted X to the^ of x to the^ 8
because 8 is equal to x ^ x ^ 8 so let's
just substitute
in we end up with X to the power of x to
the power of x to the power of x to the^
of 8 and that is equal to
8 but why would we stop here we again
have eight in the exponent and we know
that 8 is exactly equal to the entire
left side so we could substitute one
more time
so let's just bring in this eight and
we're going to substitute in again so
I'm going to have to move this around to
create some room and we want to
substitute in the entire left hand side
for eight so we go ahead and substitute
in and we end up with X to the power of
x to the power of x to the power of x to
the power of x to the power of x to the
power of x to the power of x to the^ of
8 this is all equal to
8 so you can imagine we could continue
this
pattern so if we take the limit we would
end up with something like X to the^ of
x to the^ of X repeated infinitely many
times is all equal to 8 but now even
though it looks like we've made progress
we've run into a
problem this equation actually has no
solution if you take a look at the graph
of x ^ x to the^ X infinitely many times
it looks something like this
this there is no solution for this graph
being equal to 8 the Y values have a
minimum of 1 over e which is
approximately
0.37 and the maximum value is e which is
2.72 so you'll never get this equation
being equal to eight so somewhere we
made a mistake but that's okay when you
try and work out a problem you don't
always get to the solution right away
but it might inspire you to think of a
problem solving technique so let's start
all over from first
principles let's think about the
equation x to the^ of 8 is equal to 8 we
have an8 in the exponent and we know
that the entire left hand side is equal
to 8 so we can substitute in X to ^ 8
for 8 if we do that we get our original
equation x ^ x to ^ of 8 is equal to 8
so if we could somehow solve the
equation x ^ 8 is equal to 8 we will
have found a solution to x ^ x to the^
of 8 is equal to 8 to do that we take
both sides of the equation to the^ of 1
over 8 so that we get X is equal to 8 ^
of 1 8 which is approximately equal to
1.
297 so if you didn't see this trick
directly here's another way you could
solve the problem let's do the
substitution Y is equal to x ^ of 8 so
we could substitute in Y for the
exponent so we have x to the Y is equal
to 8 but if Y is equal to x ^ 8 we can
take both sides to the^ of 1 8 so that X
is equal to y ^ 1 over8 we can then
substitute in here so we have y ^ 1 over
8 raised to the^ Y is equal to
8 we have a power raised to a power so
we can multiply them so we get y ra to^
of Y / 8 is equal to
8 now let's take both sides to the power
of 8 again we have a power to a power so
we multiply that through so this will be
y to the^ of Y is equal to 8 to the^ of
8 and now we can easily see that Y is
equal to 8 is a solution so substituting
that in we get X is equal to 8 to^ of 1
/ 8 and that's the
answer now let's just generalize this
suppose we have X to the^ a is equal to
a here x and a are positive real
numbers now the exponent a is exactly
equal to the entire left hand side which
is X to the power of a so we can
substitute in to x to the power of x ^
of a is equal to a we could of course
substitute in again for the exponent a
and then we would get x to^ x to^ x to^
a is equal to a so we can see all of
these equations would have the same
solution as X the^ of a is equal to a
and of course that first equation can be
solved by taking both sides to the^ 1/ a
so you get X is equal to a to the^
raised to the 1 / a so just for fun I
will end the video with a couple of
challenges what if you had X to ^ of x
to the power of 3 is equal to 3 then X
to the^ of x to the power of x to the
power of Pi is equal to PI what's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time